it is straining the limits of our
ability to provide care for New Yorkers
in need and it is burning through our
City's budget we expect to spend at
least one billion dollars by the end of
the fiscal year on this crisis
New York city mayor Eric Adams declaring
a state of emergency yesterday as more
than 17 thousand migrants have been
bussed to the Big Apple in recent months
the Democrat pleading with President
Biden to take action as the city is set
to spend one billion dollars this year
here to react is New York representative
Nicole malliotakis uh congresswoman
great to have you on the program I'm
curious when you hear mayor Adams and
his tone rhetoric even the words that
he's now using do you hear a lack of
self-awareness or hypocrisy or do you
actually hear a leader beginning to see
the light
well I think he's beginning to see the
light because this is absolutely
unsustainable and it is placing a
tremendous burden on the people of New
York City one billion dollars at a time
when New Yorkers can't afford to keep
their own roofs over their heads and
they're struggling to pay for food with
this High inflation but the mayor is
also hypocritical because he refuses to
address New York City's Sanctuary status
predominantly the the the the part that
prohibits nyp from even cooperating with
deportation if an individual commits a
crime here in New York City but really
he throughout that entire speech I saw
the whole speech he did not call out
President Biden by name or call for
President Biden to secure the Border he
talked about some decompression
strategy for the Border I don't know
what that means he needs to tell
President Biden to secure the Border
stop the nonsense reinstate the policies
under President Trump that were working
and stem the flow and restored order to
this Asylum application process so to
your point let's take a quick look look
at some of what he had to say because I
think you're right he neglected to get
down to Brass tax to be specific but boy
he's flirting with getting to the issue
listen to this
the time for Aid to New York is now
we need help from the federal government
help from the state of New York and
Congress must pass emergency Financial
relief for our city we need a bipartisan
effort to deliver
long-awaited immigration reforms so we
can offer people a safe and legal path
to the American dream so as he's
speaking by the way congresswoman on the
screen he's got like a PowerPoint
presentation next to him and it does say
Federal action now we can hear he's
asking for money and he's doing the
Democratic thing of comprehensive
immigration reform but I I do wonder you
know the the plan by Ron DeSantis and
Greg Abbott and you know border state
Governors who've sent illegal immigrants
to places like New York City to make
them see the light it does I actually
wonder if Adams is on the verge of
saying uh secure the southern border
well what I'll say is that President
Biden had been flying in individuals uh
for a long time now and he didn't say
anything about it and neither did our
governor and in fact they've
incentivized this crisis uh by offering
illegal immigrants uh so many different
benefits benefits in some cases that
American citizens don't even receive
like so for example Kathy Holcomb wanted
to give some unemployment Assistance or
stimulus checks rather to those who are
in the country illegally which she did
she created a fund for that but if you
were a mother a single mother of three
uh you earn a hundred thousand dollars
in New York and you got nothing from
Kathy hulkel you know same thing with
other health care benefits for seniors
who are here illegally but yet our
senior citizens are struggling but the
one thing is this we're not going to get
any action until Republicans take back
the house that's evident the president
created this crisis the vice president
ignores the crisis and Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer won't bring any of our
solutions to the floor for a vote
including our comprehensive border
Security Act for America so we need to
flip the house we need to end one party
rule in New York as well and that's the
only way we're going to get some action
on this and you don't need more money in
New York City you need to secure the
southern border Congressman Nicole
maritakis thank you so much I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis